un nuevo hallazgo en la investigación
del intento de homicidio contra cristina
fernández el hombre que presionó el
gatillo de un arma a unos cuantos metros
de la vicepresidenta de argentina no
actuó solo la pareja del hombre de 35
años lo habría acompañado en el atentado
del primero de septiembre gracias a
vídeos registrados por cámaras de
seguridad la policía se percató que
brenda uliarte de 23 años acompañó a su
novio cuando pretendía atentar contra la
vida de fernández además estas
fotografías halladas en los teléfonos de
la pareja donde se ven posando con un
arma similar a la que estaba acusó para
disparar contra la ex presidenta de
argentina la implicaron en el atentado
uriarte había declarado inicialmente
quien no haya visto a su novia en las 48
horas anteriores del ataque entretanto
sábado quien está imputado por el delito
de intento de homicidio agravado fue
llevado ante los tribunales este martes
6 de septiembre pero aún no ha revelado
las causas que lo motivaron a intentar
cometer el crimen sabag nació en brasil
pero bien argentina desde niños según
las autoridades fue detenido en 2021 por
portación de arma blanca lleva un
símbolo nazi tatuado en el brazo y
acostumbrada a compartir mensajes de
odio por medio de redes sociales